[Musique]
dans le débat sur france 24 une émission
spéciale bientôt cinq mois de guerre en
ukraine et le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov a affirmé que les
objectifs militaires de la russie ne se
limitait plus à l'est du pays mais
concernait également d'autres
territoires et pourrait encore s'étendre
en russie la propagande et la répression
contre toute voix opposantes se renforce
nous allons regarder ensemble reportage
de notre envoyé spécial en russie
carénage à bourg qui montre le régime de
plus en plus répressif de vladimir
poutine depuis le début de l'offensive
en ukraine russie de poutine entre
propagande et répression c'est le thème
de ce débat avec justement karina
chahbour qui est rentré de russie a tout
récemment nom qui est avec nous à paris
en plateau karina bonsoir vous avez
réalisé donc le reportage que nous
allons regarder ensemble et vous le
comme entrée avec nous à côté de vous
natalia morozova bonsoir bienvenue dans
le débat vous êtes avocate de l'omg
mémorial international mémorial qui a
donné une conférence de presse à paris
hier mémorial qui a été dissoute par
vladimir poutine vous nous raconterez
tout cela en face des vhu bruno daroux
chroniqueur internationale france 24
bonsoir bruno sur ce faux avant de
démarrer cette discussion je vous
propose donc de regarde de regarder ce
reportage de karina chahbour chronique
d'une russie aux ordres c'est tout de
suite
cette image je n'aurais pas dû la filmer
la caméra de vidéosurveillance de la
mairie m'a repéré
deux hommes sortent
direction le commissariat
la police a arrêté une journaliste
française qui filmait des militants dans
la région d'ivanovo que s'est il passé
dans la russie de vladimir poutine
interviewé des opposants à la guerre en
ukraine
n'est pas sans risque
[Musique]
dès le début mon statut était incertain
j'avais mon visa presse mais pas
d'accréditation sorte de permis de
travail pour journalistes le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères n'en
délivrent plus la france et ses médias
sont jugés inamicaux
[Musique]
au
jus est
accusé de propagande les médias russes
sont interdits de diffusion en europe et
en amérique
les 27 états membres de l'union
européenne ont approuvé la mesure
d'interdiction d'ayrté france et ce
pique nique moscou mena son retour de
couper les chaînes d'information
occidental pour les mêmes raisons il ya
à vinny
prospal a gagné x x x des informations
absolument
bouchât ville martyre ou après le départ
des russes des civils sont retrouvés
abattus dans la rue
accusé de crimes de guerre
moscou nie en bloc et parle de mise en
scène du gouvernement ukrainien
depuis que vladimir poutine a décidé
d'envahir l'ukraine le mot guerre est
interdite il faut parler d'opération
spéciale
toute critique de l'armée peut valoir
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
dans ces conditions comment travailler
en russie comme journalistes étrangers
tant qu'on donne la parole aux partisans
du kremlin tout va bien
à saint pétersbourg j'ai rendez vous
dans ce restaurant surnommé le patriote
barre ici la bataille de l'information
fait rage
naama
collective
igor anic cyber français d' un collectif
chargé de défendre sur internet les
positions du gouvernement et d'attaquer
ses adversaires comme le président
français qui a livré des canons caesar à
l'ukraine
quand on monte un super lot me dire que
je sois
plus pop rock
derrière leur écran ces jeunes
prétendent démentir les fausses
informations venues de l'ouest et
d'ukraine
dégâts de cyberfront
nous indiquent qu'ils diffusent des
informations
[Musique]
disons pas totalement juste sur les
réseaux sociaux
et puis après nous nous signalons ce
contenu
moi je cherche les autres fils de
discussion avec qui nous pouvons
collaborer les tchats patriotique il y
en a beaucoup sur télégramme surtout
depuis le début de l'opération spéciale
sur notre oeil le groupe compte plus de
cent mille abonnés sur télégramme la
plupart disent travailler dans le
numérique
et venir ici à titre bénévole pour la
patrie
on n'a pas d'horaires strictes ici je
viens quand j'ai le temps on ne nous dit
pas vous devez écrire 20 ou 300
commentaires ici je peux je le fais ne
sait pas toujours le cas
80 bd
comment peut-on rester indifférent quand
il ya une guerre d'information contre la
russie depuis si longtemps
tout le monde sait que les américains
dépensent beaucoup sans se cacher les
lobbies de washington les grandes
sociétés de relations publiques le fonds
soros
qui financent ces guerriers de l'info
sont ils tous bénévoles
et à qui appartient le restaurant face à
ces questions malaise dans la salle
[Applaudissements]
cette journaliste a réussi à infiltrer
cyberfront
elle s'est fait recruter sous une fausse
identité
sa mission cibler les opposants à la
guerre en publiant 200 commentaires par
jour
le travail est rémunéré plus de 800
euros par mois
dans son reportage elle décrit une armée
de trolls professionnels
très vite après publication elle reçoit
des menaces
on m'a fait comprendre que les soi
disant chef de cette usine à troll
préparer quelque chose contre moi
du coup je ne suis pas resté chez moi
pendant une semaine je n'utilisais pas
mon téléphone
c'était stressant mais ça va rien de
grave n'est arrivé
selon la journaliste derrière cyberfront
plane l'ombre d'evgeny prigogine
un puissant homme d'affaires ayant fait
fortune dans la restauration
on l'appelle le cuisinier poutine
l'homme est surtout lié au groupe wagner
l'armée de l'ombre du kremlin
des mercenaires très actif en ukraine en
afrique ou au moyen-orient
une milice accusé de multiples exactions
[Musique]
l'oligarque est aussi à la tête de 195
média spécialisée dans la désinformation
et la propagande pro kremlin
le fbi a il accuse d'ingérence dans les
élections américaines de 2016
lors de son infiltration
la journaliste a eu affaire à un homme
aux ordres de prix jean
la personne qui organisait le
recrutement est dans le bureau duquel on
travaillait s'appelait alexane écrit
l'ofs
d'après mes sources auparavant ils
étaient employés par des sociétés
connues aux états unis pour être lié à
yevgeny prigogine
[Musique]
selon elle alex est une écrit love
travaillait pour class 7 mix info et nos
infos trois filiales de l'internet
reasearch agency muszyna troll de
prigogine accusé d'être au coeur de la
campagne de désinformation en faveur de
donald trump
en avril dernier sur un autre site
internet appartenant à prigogine n'écrit
love se présente comme l'organisateur du
mouvement
était
une fois
en quittant le patriote barre j'avais
ramassé ce ticket laissé sur une table
en haut le nom du propriétaire
le groupe concorde
derguini prigogine
[Applaudissements]
à cette offensive numérique
s'ajoute une répression accrue
pour éviter la prison la plupart des
médias indépendants se sont tus
quant aux rares opposants il leur est
interdit de manifester
en avril dernier la militante olga gorée
ligue décide de braver la loi
quand je suis arrivé j'ai vu que la
police était déjà sur place et j'ai eu
peur de me faire arrêter avant même
d'avoir le temps de sortir ma pancarte
elle était dans mon sac mais j'ai réussi
à la sortir
honnêtement j'ai eu peur d'aller
manifester mais j'ai décidé de le faire
parce qu'il le faut on ne peut pas
rester silencieux
arrêté elle écope d'une double amende de
1200 euros
dernier avertissement avant la prison
les gars travaillent pour une ong de
défense des droits de l'homme début mars
son directeur lance une pétition contre
la guerre signée par plus d'un million
de personnes dans les jours suivants lo
ng est la cible d'intimidations
les caméras ont été recouvertes de
peinture on a eu beaucoup de mal à tout
nettoyé ici ils ont tracé avait gelé
recouvert moi-même de peinture et par la
nzz
et v2 lettre qui s'affiche sur les chars
russes
symbole du soutien à vladimir poutine et
à sa guerre en ukraine
l'entrée de l'omg a aussi été aspergée
d'excréments
en
tout cas ils n'ont peur de rien pour
venir déverser leurs sauts il faut être
courageux pour faire ça devant les
caméras
c'est pas du courage quand tu sais que
tu ne risques rien que tu es protéger
un cadavres de chats est aussi placée
devant la porte
ok ils ont jeté de la merde sur la porte
mais tuer un animal
mais bon c'est comme ça on n'a pas le
choix
aujourd'hui l'eau angie est classé
agents de l'étranger elle est soumise à
de multiples contrôles et risque de
lourdes sanctions
son directeur a fui le pays
depuis le 24 février plus de 16000
russes ont été arrêtés pour s'être élevé
contre la guerre
pendant ce temps chez cyberfront on
parle liberté d'expression et courtoisie
pour
moi je te passe
igor a tout à fait raison on ne fait pas
d'attaqués personnelles
comme on voit souvent sur les réseaux
sociaux
on est un pays libre chacun peut dire ce
qu'il pense nous écoutons et nous
discutons et c'est du dialogue émergent
à mille kilomètres de là dans la petite
ville de choï à
autre son de cloche
sergei baisser l'offre est informaticien
il sort tout juste de prison
sur les douze jours j'en ai passé trois
dans une cellule minuscule d'un mètre et
demi sur un mètre et demi
un trou à rats
je n'ai pas dormi pendant trois jours
c'était une vraie torture
sergei attend son procès ils risquent de
retourner derrière les barreaux son
crime avoir tagué non à la guerre sur la
façade de la mairie
je les fais parce que j'étais contre la
guerre en ukraine parce qu'on n'a plus
le choix la liberté de manifester ou de
s'exprimer n'existe plus c'était tout ce
qu'il nous restait
c'est d'ailleurs en filmant cette façade
nettoyer que je suis repéré
ces fonctionnaires me contrôler
et appelle la police
dans ce commissariat je suis longuement
interrogé sur le but du reportage
sergei l'activiste est aussi interpellé
libérer le premier il dénonce aussitôt
l'arrestation
ou lire steve jobs
je reçois une amende de 35 euros
motif officiel
journalistes non accrédités
les réseaux sociaux se déchaîne on nous
reproche surtout d'avoir donné la parole
à un opposant la presse étrangère
continue de glorifier les collaborateurs
des nazis ukrainien
combien de temps encore les journalistes
des médias étrangers
scheer ont-ils sur la russie en faisant
la promotion des partisans d uc rhône
asie
la vidéo de mon arrestation et diffusée
en ligne
et même mes papiers d'identité avec mon
adresse personnelle
un dernier coup de pression il est temps
de quitter la russie
[Applaudissements]
dans la ville voisine d'ivanovo j'ai
juste le temps de récupérer les images
d'autres activistes
[Musique]
ceux là sont poursuivis pour avoir
distribué
1984 de george orwell
ce roman sur l'enfer totalitaire est
devenu un symbole de résistance à la
guerre en ukraine
[Musique]
dans les usines à troll du pays jour
après jour les alliés du kremlin refont
le monde
seule voix autorisées dans une russie en
guerre où tout avis contraire n'a plus
sa place
karine achats vous êtes avec nous ce
soir bon d'abord effectivement il s'agit
de répression et de propagande si on
prend d'abord justement ce thème de la
répression on voit bien dans votre
reportage qui est devenu quasiment
impossible d'être journaliste d'exercer
son métier de journaliste d'être
opposant en russie en particulier pour
les russes a encore beaucoup plus que
pour les étrangers et vous avez donc
vous même fait l'objet d'une arrestation
au moment où vous filmer ce que vous
racontez dans votre film racontez nous
un peu ce qui s'est passé mais c'est
d'ailleurs enfin la raison pour laquelle
j'ai fait quelque chose auquel on est
peu habitué en tant que journaliste qui
est de raconter à la première personne
parce qu'effectivement c'est un cas
d'école le fait de se faire arrêter non
pas parce que c'est une mairie ou autre
chose mais bien parce que j'étais avec
un opposant les deux personnes qui sont
sorties de la mairie ont tout de suite
vu que j'étais avec sergey shilov ils
ont vu qu'il y avait un micro et là tout
de suite les choses se sont compliquées
ils ont appelé la police la police est
arrivée il ya eu un contrôle d'identité
et ensuite on a été emmené au
commissariat séparés et moi même j'ai
été donc longuement interrogé pendant
six heures par tout un tas qu'est-ce qui
vous ont demandé en principalement ce
qu'ils voulaient savoir c'était pourquoi
une journaliste occidental faisait tout
ce trajet chouïa c'est une petite ville
qui se trouve à mille kilomètres environ
de moscou pourquoi faire tout ce trajet
danse pour cette belle bourgade pour
aller voir cette personne m'a bien fait
comprendre que c'était une mauvaise
personne qu'elle avait déjà reçu des
amendes qu'elle avait déjà fait de la
prison sergueï en question absolument
alors qu' il y avait plein de bonnes
personnes à voir atchia notamment le
commissaire qui m'a sorti sa veste avec
ses médailles en disant voilà il ya des
bonnes personnes qui font des bonnes
choses pour la patrie pourquoi vous êtes
venus voir cette personne qui vous a
donné son contact comment vous l'avez
trouvée est ce que vous avez été payé
pour la voir voilà le genre de questions
qu'on a posés pendant six heures est ce
que vous avez eu peur un petit moment où
partout oui je peins évidemment c'est
pas c'est pas agréable alors la
principale crainte on le voit d'ailleurs
que je tremble ma caméra tremblée et
c'est ma première réaction ça a été de
couper la caméra et de cacher ma carte
mémoire parce que je me suis dit je me
faire piquer mon matériel après j'ai eu
très peur pour sergei pour la personne
avec qui je travaillais aussi et puis
finalement si un gars y est parti au
bout de trois heures lui on a il n'a pas
eu de la peine d'amendé n'a rien eu une
amende c'est grave en russie même si ses
35 euros la prochaine pour moi c'était
clairement l'exclusion du pays et pour
sergei c'est clairement la prison dont
il était temps pour vous de quitter le
pays un mot justement sur ces opposants
enfin on voit tout de même y continue à
rien a de moins en moins mais il
continue qu est-ce qu il risque 15 ans
de prison ont dit aujourd'hui si vous
parlez de guerre au lieu de parler d'eux
comment c'est le terme heureux
opérations spéciales opération tout
simplement ils risquent ils risquent la
prison et dans des conditions parfois à
300 la vue pour l'opposant numéro 1
navalni dans une colonie pénitentiaire
on peut pas leur en manque pas lui
rendre visite
c'est très très compliqué avec parfois
des tentatives d'empoisonnement fin ça
peut aller très très loin
nathalie amoureuse où va votre réaction
quand vous voyez ce reportage
d'abord je dois dire que c'est aux
violations de la loi car vous êtes
s'était retenu six 6 heures un
commissariat de police parce que
normalement ça doit être dur et que
trois heures
j'étais dans une dune départ j'étais
dans un statut incertain parce que
j'étais à moitié en règle j'avais un
visa presse mais j'avais pas
l'accréditation qui va comme un permis
de travail pour un journaliste et je
pense qu'ils ont d'ailleurs trouvé que
ça comme motif pour me donner une amende
donc voilà je jouais c'était depuis le
début je savais qu'à tout moment je
pouvais me faire contrôler me faire
arrêter ses bus mais leurs mimiques vous
vous êtes avocat atteindre justement de
l'association mémorial l'association
mémorial qui est donc enquête sur les
crimes commis du temps de staline donc
pour des familles russes et qui a été
dissoute un peu avant d'ailleurs
l'offensive en ukraine tout à fait et
donc je crois que c'est le préparation
pour la guerre c'était la raison
principale pour cordes du sud de
l'organisation mémorial donc une memri
internationale qui travaille justement
sur les crimes pendant
le boxster aignan et l'organisation même
réalisateur de droit allemand qui lui ne
se souciant des opposants aussi est
fait
et défend d'être humains actuels ici et
maintenant et vous allez donner une
conférence de presse à paris donc malgré
cette dissolution vous continuez le
combat on continue à travailler oui on a
créé l'organisation qui s'appelle de
saint-albert durrmann mémorial
et donc on va continuer à travailler
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de parce que les
gens en a besoin de nous parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de travail pour nous pour des
défenseurs des droits humains parce que
vu le fait de circonstance et
mémorielles était le premier à
investiguer les crimes de guerre
notamment en tchétchénie à l'époque en
première et deuxième guerre en
tchétchénie à la fin des années 90 et là
vous ne pouvez en fait à être actif
qu'en dehors de russie aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous risquez si vous
apparaissez aujourd'hui c'est un agent
de l'étranger c'est saint martial oui ma
mère elle est toujours et c'était une
des premières organisations qui étaient
déclarés agents de l'étranger et c'était
pour nous c'était toujours à partir de
2012 quand c'est un loi est entrée en
vigueur c'est pour nous c'était l'épée
de damocles le mot démocratie merci et
est donc c'était un
temps dix ans dix ans était tombé et
donc
on était liquidée mais maintenant on ne
risque parce qu'on a déjà nommé la
guerre la guerre et on risque toujours
d'avoir d'abord
l'amande et deuxièmement ce sera au camp
me disait karine ce sera carrément les
prisons et il y a une semaine c'était la
première verdict est donc le député
municipal alexis gorzow a été creusé
pour s'étendre de présence et ans de
prison pour lui quel est son rôle à
memorial non il n'était pas il n'était
pas de mémorial mais c'était une
militants
de moscou et j'étais député municipal et
c'était première heure dicte mais juste
30 ans de prison donc c'est un de
présent bruno daroux votre réaction
quand vous avez vous voyez le reportage
de karina poutine on sait qu'il était
déjà autoritaire mais là on est passé à
une autre dimension qui ne cette
répression oui disons qu'en fait le
déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine a
permis aussi à l'intérieur de
verrouiller encore plus un système qui
commençait déjà à être sérieusement
verrouillé depuis le début des années
2000 en passant par la réécriture de du
récit national l'imposition déjà d'une
vérité historique donc un véritable
travail pour imposer une mémoire unique
en quelque sorte à l'ensemble des russes
concernant c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
ce qui est parfois un peu difficile à
comprendre pour des téléspectateurs qui
vivent à l'étranger le terme de nazis
résonne très fortement chez les russes
parce que il ya une propagande
réellement depuis le début des années
2000 pour faire en sorte que ce qui
s'est passé pendant ce qu'ils appellent
la grande guerre patriotique donc la
guerre de l'union soviétique contre
l'allemagne à partir de juin 1941 pour
que cette guerre il n'y ait qu'un seul
récit qui évacue toutes les zones
d'ombré qui a eu donc il ya eu tout un
travail qui a quand même été fait
parallèlement d'ailleurs à la répression
graduelle contre contre les ong à la
fois sur ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette grande guerre patriotique mais
aussi sur les épisodes plus sombres de
la période stalinienne et le pouvoir
voilà je parle sous votre contrôle est
même allé jusqu'à de manière assez je
sais pas quel terme employer mais pour
contrecarrer les actions de
d'organisations comme mémorial qui non
seulement donner les noms des victimes
des répressions mais aussi les noms des
responsables de ces victimes dont
beaucoup le responsable du nkvd à
l'époque puis du du kgb le le
gouvernement de l'émirat poutine est
allé jusqu à encadrer ce récit terrible
non ils n'ont pas nier les périodes
sombres de la période stalinienne par
exemple mais ils ont fait en sorte par
exemple qu'il ya un mémorial qui a été
augurer mais yahoo mais il ya aucun nom
de victimes par exemple dont vladimir
poutine dans plusieurs interviews a dit
oui il y a eu des choses très violentes
qui se sont déroulées sous staline et il
ya trop de gens qui ont souffert il ya
des millions de gens qui ont souffert
mais il ne va pas plus loin
certains épisodes comme ça sont soit
minimisée soit carrément passés sous
silence et ce travail va même jusque
dans le travail de l'éducation nationale
jusqu'à la réécriture des manuels
scolaires au fur et à mesure tout ce qui
concernait par exemple la période
programme des de la répression delà de
la grande purge dans les années 1930
nous sommes à occuper une place de plus
en plus petit ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
selon un centre assez indépendant qui
s'appelle levada je crois par exemple
plus de la moitié des 18 24 ans ignore
quasiment tout de ce qui s'est passé de
sombrer de terribles en terme de
répression pendant laquelle sa ligne
alors oui il ya eu quand même les
fiancés la mémoire nous fait
cette ce travail mémoriel réel auprès de
la population russe qui explique je
pense en partie aujourd'hui pourquoi la
propagande actuelle finalement
fonctionne plutôt bien auprès d'une
grande partie de la majorité parce que
les gens ont fini par croire à ce récit
absolument verrouillé et ce récit unique
le tout allant avec une répression de
plus en plus féroce contre les opposants
et les ong
comme on le voit dans le reportage de
karina justement caréna dans votre
reportage on voit à quel point cette
propagande est extrêmement organisés à
vous dites d'ailleurs dans votre portage
que prigogine donc le chef de la force
wagner est derrière cette équipe que
vous avez filmé que c'est un faisceau
d'indicés concordants qui qui ramènerait
à la figure de priego chine qui est un
homme de saint pétersbourg très
important à saint pétersbourg et la
journaliste donc deux fronts tant qu'à
nice un club je crois que j'ai
interviewés elle a établi un lien avec
alex et hymne écrit l'ofs qui est un
homme de la galaxie prigogine et puis
ensuite le lendemain je me suis donc
rendu dans ce patriote barre
et j'ai voulu savoir qui était derrière
j'ai posé la question on me répondait
pas j'ai consommé j'ai demandé mon
ticket de caisse on m'a dit non non
c'est igor qui vous invite j'ai insisté
on n'a pas voulu me faire payer et du
coup j'ai dû chiper un ticket de caisse
sur une table voisine et là j'ai poussé
établit le lien avec le groupe concorde
qui appartient donc à prigogine j'en ai
parlé à la journaliste de francs en cas
et finalement il a fait la même démarche
elle est allée elle était jamais allé
elle avait en fait parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que le patriote bars et la
façade officiel de cyberfront derrière
il ya une usine à troll qui est là qu
elle a infiltré la chasse aux usines à
troll c'est quand même le terme que vous
utilisez karina parce qu'ils utilisent
effectivement ces trolls qui payent des
gens des souvent qu'ils sentent d'études
800 euros ça a l'air d'être peu mais en
fait c'est un bon salaire là bas pour
des jeunes et ils ont un quota de
commentaire à faire sur les réseaux
sociaux pour cibler les traîtres à la
patrie ou encontre au contraire relayer
la propagande pro kremlin natalia
morozova est ce que les russes
finalement achète propagande et ce
qu'ils croient tout cela oui au final
au fond dans leur majorité d'un amant
j'ai arrêté je crois que oui
malheureusement il y a des gens actifs
qui vers savoir que ce qui se passe et
qui lisent des chaînes
télégramme spécial et que lise
l'information sous vpn parce que toute
l'information interdit maintenant elle
est interdite mais vous pouvez quand
même la trouver on ne peut pas d'
excuses qu'il n'y a pas d'informations
on ne peut pas ses excuses à maintenant
sauf pour des gens peut-être de assez
âgées qui ne regardent que la télé mais
pour les jeanjean il n'y a pas d'
excuses qu'on ne savait pas comme on
disait dans les années
30 donc s'il n'y a pas d'excusé si on
veut savoir en deux c'est donc pour moi
il n'y va pas parce que c'est par
caresser par obéissance parce qu'ils ont
choisi de rester dans le train oui et
c'est à peu près ça parce que c est bien
ça me rappelle de l'époque de mon
enfance des années 70 80 quand on avait
peur de dire quelque chose alors que si
on dise quelque chose si on parle de
politique à ce ça peut produire un effet
indésirable et donc on est on a choisi
de vivre sa vie privée et on se mêle pas
de la politique et
mon avis c'est en dessous que ce que
s'est passé aujourd'hui donc on ne mène
pas que le politique on ne laisse vivre
en paix et donc on va vivre notre vie
notre petite vie et le gouvernement ne
regarde pas bruno la guerre de
l'information elle est essentielle dans
cette guerre en ukraine dont il ya cette
propagande russe il ya aussi de la
propagande deux côté ukrainien
même si effectivement côté russe à un
autre niveau puisque c'est la russie
l'agresseur oui non seulement tu joues
si l'agresseur mais
concernant le côté ukrainien même si
évidemment c'est très loin d'être
parfait l'ukraine depuis la révolution
de 2004 puis au maïdo en 2014 était
quand même sur la voie d'une
démocratisation
même si encore beaucoup de chemin à
faire notamment en matière de lutte
contre la corruption donc on n'était pas
tout à fait quand même dans le même
registre en terme d'ampleur s'empêche
pas sur certains épisodes une forme de
guerre mémorial entre la russie
l'ukraine parce qu'il faut toujours
avoir en tête que vladimir poutine je
pense est assez sérieux quand il
explique il l'a expliqué dans dans un
texte l'été dernier jeu qui s'appelle de
l'unité historique entre les russes et
les ukrainiens il l'a redit trois jours
avant de déclencher son offensive à la
télévision et là il a longuement
développé sa thèse selon laquelle la
l'existence même si vous voulez de
l'état ukrainien est une création
purement artificielle et que en fait il
faut recréer un peu la grande route ils
sont ici ou alors ce qu'on appelait a le
droit à l'époque des tsars là la
nouvelle russie qui était donc toute la
partie sud est de l'ukraine jusqu'à
carson nikolaïev et odessa qui ne
faisait pas partie de l'ukraine à
l'époque qui faisait partie de la russie
et donc il est il est assez sérieux là
dessus et donc en réaction du côté de
kiev il y a eu des ripostes un peu
mémorielle si vous voulez y compris
cessé de monter entre kiev et moscou
jusqu'à la figure du du premier
dirigeant qui venait de kiev je pense
vladimir le grand entre 956 et 1015 je
crois donc vladimir pour le grand et
lumière volodymyr pour les ukrainiens et
le présent pour ocean qu ils craignent
un par exemple avait expliqué que ce
volodymyr au contraire était le premier
vrai dirigeants ukrainiens puisqu'il
avait orienté l'ukraine vers le
christianisme et les relations avec les
pays occidentaux donc il ya une guerre
de huy de propagande une guerre sur
l'histoire c'est très très important un
parce que c'est pour ça que c'est en
permanence utilisé par vladimir poutine
quand il explique à sa population qu'il
va combattre le nazisme ukrainiens ou
une cro nazisme un moment donné si un
voile à lui que lui trop luc roby
nazisme
ça c'est assez sérieux en fait il pense
alors après il ya beaucoup de
d'utilisation d'instrumentalisation il
ya eu des groupes ultra nationalistes y
compris pendant la période de maidan en
2014 la pièce est parfois ont repris des
slogans de ces groupes et ça a été
utilisé par part à la propagande aux
russes pour dames et vous voyez ce pays
est dirigé par des nazis et tout ça
cette petite musique est montée un peu
avant 2014 il ya eu l'élection de la
crimée et tout ça a continué aussi un
deux puis il faut bien voir que il ya
une espèce de guerre de propagande et
d'information qui est en place depuis
2014 entre la russie et l'ukraine
carénage justement on a vu en cette
séquence où il ya écrit macron tuent des
civils donc là aussi il cible en ce
moment emmanuel macron depuis la vente
de ces fameux césar je pense que c'était
aussi fait un peu exprès parce qu'il
savait qu'une journaliste il accueillait
une journaliste française donc ils ont
décidé prendre une cible française mais
ça fait effectivement ils ont ciblé
aussi d'autres d'autres personnalités
occidentales
l'ancien premier ministre britannique où
le président américain donc c'est
certain clairement leur cible c'est
aussi le monde occidental
ne dis pas là mais un autre moment il le
dit c'est vraiment natalia ment aux as
que vous êtes surprise par les
instruments justement par ces trolls par
tout tous ces outils utilisés tout de
même par la propagande russe non pas du
tout parce qu'on est déjà l'habitude
parce que je connaissais adp mais ce que
je
ce que m'a étonné quand même c'est
l'ampleur maintenant de propagande russe
parce que je suis quelques quelques
chaînes de propagandistes russe juste
pour voir comment ça se passe et je sais
que maintenant toujours c'est comment
ils renversent
randers l'information la vraie et donc
pardon excusez moi c'est les cadres de
liquidation du emerald tribunal voir
c'est ça c'était la décision donc de
wayne mémorial et on a un devoir à
l'image donc votre émotion ouais pardon
à et donc on prend des faits et on les
retourne comme ça et on dit que c'est
pas nous c'est abuja c'est pas nous
c'est les démocraties montage de karine
white l'un des interlocuteurs du cyber
fronde dit nous sommes un pays où on
peut s'exprimer librement oui c'est
effectivement on retourne complètement
les faits dans une logique et
l'utilisation de ce terme n'est tout de
même pas qualifier les ukrainiens ça va
oui c'est vrai c'est très bien choisi
parce que à mon avis et ses propres
outils le mythe fondateur c'est la
grande guerre patriotique
quand on appelle un grossiste etc c'est
très bien choisi parce que pour les gens
qui pour l'étudiant russe ça ça ça
s'adresse directement à
l'inconscient parce que c'est notre
enfance ses mythes qu'on est con avec
hong kong qu'on connaît tous ses cdd 0
de cette guerre et quand on parle de
nazis ça vient tout de suite c'est
céline on sera énormément france heymans
émotionnel c'est vraiment
volonté mémorielle quand même de la part
de poutine qui âge qui a fait un peu un
syncrétisme entre le tout ce qui fondait
un peu l'urss et les mythes de l'urss et
avant la russie tsariste il a fait une
forme de jeu pas comment dire de
composites pour réécrire l'histoire et
surtout effacer la période terrible à
ses yeux des années 90 c'est émotionnel
à et puis l'instrumentalise
effectivement quelque chose de très fort
sur la grande guerre patriotique qui
touche toutes les familles dont tous
quelqu'un de de leur famille qui avec
qui s'est battue ou qui est mort sur le
franc ou qui a souffert de la guerre
d'une façon ou d'une autre façon très
prégnante 1 malgré le fait que la
régression stalinien aussi est là elle a
touché tout aussi mais surtout on a
choisi sept mille fondateur la guerre la
guerre boatwright icna grande guerre
patriotique
avec ce récit alors bruno sur les buts
de guerre en ukraine sergueï lavrov
s'est exprimé il ya quelques jours tout
récemment le chef de la diplomatie russe
il a dit que les objectifs militaires de
la russie ne se limitait plus à l'est du
pays mais concerne a également d'autres
territoires et qui pourrait encore
s'étendre pourquoi cette communication
maintenant est ce que ça veut dire
clairement que la guerre va durer
soit c'est une déclaration pour envoyer
le message que la guerre va durer soit
c'est une déclaration pour indiquer que
les russes finalement rencontrent des
difficultés et que pour autant ils ne
sont pas prêts à baisser les armes et
qu'on en revient quand même du coup aux
objectifs initiaux qui avaient été
martelée par vladimir poutine le 24
février quand l'invasion a commencé qui
était donc la dénazification
du régime fini à la démilitarisation de
l'ukraine et plus généralement la
désorganisation la désoccidentalisation
du pays enfin au départ quand même il
faut le rappeler les objectifs
concernaient l'ensemble de l'ukraine et
la dénazification ça voulait dire le
renversement du régime puisque c'étaient
des nazis s'étaient pas des démocrates
zelensky et sa clique il les avait même
traité je crois de dégénérer de drogués
enfin bon voilà tous les vices du monde
seul et donc ils reprennent
difficultés pour l'armée russe qui se
sont concentrés sur le dos de base donc
il ya eu un récent le disant qu'ils
voient la qui s'est développée là dessus
en disant notre efforts se concentrent
voilà sur le dombass et sur l'est est
aussi un peu le le sud-est et maintenant
il ya à nouveau cette ce message qui est
envoyé par sergueï lavrov pour dire
finalement les choses ne sont pas
terminés donc ça veut peut-être dire
qu'on s'installe dans une guerre d'usure
mais ça veut peut-être dire aussi que
les livraisons d'armements des
occidentaux aux ukrainiens permettent
aux ukrainiens finalement quand même de
maintenir ligne de front sur l'homme bon
il ya part on n'a pas de carte clamé
progression dans le bon boss des russes
elle est très très très lente quand même
elle et elle est meurtrière lorsqu'il
pilonnages d'artillerie mais il ya quand
même une sorte de ligne de front qui
s'instaure et alors dans le sud tu peux
être car sonia même début de contre
attaque de la part des ukrainiens
notamment autour autour de carson karina
vous qui êtes allé deux fois donc en
russie récemment vous avez donc
rencontré des russes dans leur vie de
tous les jours est ce que est ce qu ils
souffrent d'abord parce que des
sanctions économiques est ce qui a un
impact à moscou auprès des moscovites ou
pas est ce qu'il est ce que vous sentez
qu'il
n'évoque pas cette guerre mais est-ce
qu'il pense que ça va tout de même duré
qu ils risquent d'être privées par
exemple d'un certain nombre de dents et
un pour l'instant magicienne et donc
deux fois dix jours pas très longtemps à
un mois d un mois d'écart et j'ai tourné
dans des entreprises qui ont quelques
problèmes d'approvisionnement mais
disons que le message c'était plutôt on
s'adapte on trouve de nouveaux
fournisseurs on se réoriente on va plus
vers l'asie plus le kazakhstan aux
produits nous mêmes plus de d'autonomie
on est habitués en 2014 on a déjà eu des
sanctions et ben du coup on a développé
notre agriculture il y avait plus ce
discours là et peut-être même un
discours de patriotisme économique qui
renforce davantage les russes qui aussi
disait beaucoup qu'il se sentait victime
de russophobie fin toujours cette bougie
nomen je l'avais renverser la paranoïa
agression lâche et les russes avec le
monde occidental il ya tout un courant
slave quoi qui explique que les valeurs
occidentales ne sont pas les mêmes pour
l'instant je dirais pas qu'ils souffrent
et pour l'instant voilà ça ça renforce
peut-être plus le patriotisme nous
faudra voir combien de temps ça dure et
si effectivement ces problèmes
d'approvisionnement ou se pose vraiment
problème dans plusieurs mois là il est
trop tôt pour le dire de paix autour de
l'impact quotidien non non non non le
quotidien des russes konaté à morozova
vous vos contacts c'est ils vous
disaient même chose finalement elle
ressent pas vraiment ces sanctions on ne
sait pas pour l'instant je crois que ça
ce sera à partir d'octobre novembre et
en plus je peux pas imaginer parce que
c'est quand même moscou ça va c'est un
petit retour de grandes villes mais vous
peut pas imaginer le niveau de pauvreté
qui est en
dans les régions russes qui ne connaît
pas les noms de ces villages et d'où
vient ce et maraudeurs qui est qu'ils
sont à l'ukraine et qui envoie les
machines à laver et de l'ukraine vers
leur village natal donc pour eux c'est
une sorte de
de l'opération spéciale quand ils vont
ils vont dans la maison des ukrainiens
pour envoyer quelque chose dans leur
village natal où il n'y a rien du tout
donc je savais qu'il y avait déjà rien
du tout sourire oui à son amie la
chanteuse ou deux comme c'est en ukraine
disent oui ils prennent ils on voit
tout à fait donc en fait ils sont assez
léonie on voit des tonnes et des tonnes
d'aidé vraiment mais de tout ce qu'ils
trouvent des portables des ordinateurs
mais aussi les soldats russes en ukraine
qui sont en fait avant voit donc tous
tout ce type de la sibérie et on peut
enfin avec l'ordinateur et le téléphone
portable ne traquait ça parce qu'il ya
je suis mignot la technique on peut les
traquer mais on en voit aussi des il ya
des reportages sur le sujet parce qu'on
nettoie aussi de frei et des machines à
laver et des tout équipement les trucs
et nagé la première est ce que ça veut
dire en fait que finalement ces rues
sont tellement habitués à un niveau de
vie si simple qu'aujourd'hui si on leur
demande de souffrir un peu plus en
allemand je ne comprends pas comment ça
peut se passer parce que c'est ces
niveaux de pauvreté telle qu on ne peut
pas aller plus bas un discours aussi que
j'ai entendu c'est un nom et des durs
nous les russes on peut affronter alors
vous les européens vous êtes des
assistés nous on sait se débrouiller
seul et puis on a notre jardin une
datcha on peut faire nos légumes fin
j'ai entendu ça plusieurs fois pour dire
quand même sur le discours
russophobe je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même assez fortement
inscrit dans la lune hiver mental de
beaucoup de russes et pas depuis
vladimir poutine de vladimir poutine en
fait il a compris qu'il fallait
réutiliser tout seul le réactiver très
fortement pour justifier ce qu'il
faisait pour justifier l'existence de
son régime et pour faire en sorte que
son régime est son pouvoir personnel
perdure centraux sans trop d'encombrés
je rappelle que normalement il peut
rester au pouvoir jusqu'en 2036 un beau
peut-être sur les russes qui ont fui la
russie parce qu'il ya un certain nombre
200 milles il me semble t'il caréna vous
avez un peu d'appréhension s'adresser à
molette natalia morozova parce qu'ils
ont quitté ce qui pouvait son parti
assez vite oui et oui c'est une prime et
c'est une crainte privilège de pouvoir
partir parce que donc foreurs au moins
de visas des moyens et setra et donc il
ya beaucoup de russes qui sont partis
dans les pays limitrophes de la russie
donc ouzbékistan libolt notamment aux
pays-bas
géorgie arménie
turquie donc les pillent les pays 3 puis
oui on n'a pas besoin de les russes
n'ont pas besoin de visa est donc
maintenant on a on peut commencer là
là bas parce que c'est par quoi faire on
n'a pas des
n'a pas de carte bancaire parce que
c'est interdit pour les russes on ne
devra pas des comptes bancaires dans les
banques européennes et les cartes
bancaires et russes ne marche pas à un
dehors d'un pays qui sont coincés parce
qu'ils peuvent même pas afin de ne pas
retourner pour le coup en russie est un
plus et ça donc et on ne sait pas on
sait pas encore faire karina un mot
peut-être encore sur ces résistances
vous avez décrit dans votre reportage
sergei cette journaliste continue ou
combat alors à leurs risques olivia elle
ne manifestent plus un puisque
clairement l sexy dance et la case
prison elle essaye de faim et se pose
des questions on essaie de voir comment
elle peut continuer son combat je dirais
que sergei et les personnes de 1984 sont
plus bravache voire même plus imprudents
ils ont un côté jeu qui ont distribué
les livres george orwell un fils avait
reçu des amendes pour ça ils ont les
amendes pour ça il nous voulons vous ont
dit qu'ils allaient continuer par
rapport aux premiers jours on a vu des
manifestations
dans les premiers jours qui ont suivi
l'invasion qui sera par contre on voit
plus dans les rues c'est fini parce que
tous ils ont tous été arrêtés en fin de
manifestation en revanche
individuellement il continue tout de
même à résister
marois qui sont entrées en vigueur et
qui interdit tout ça
c'est un train du coeur en mode mars
ces arrestations au monde but à 15 ans
d'emprisonnement
mais vous dites il continue fin certes
cela en tout cas vont essayer il y en a
un certain nombre d'autres qui essaient
de faire vivre leurs radios leur
télévision en dehors de riches ils
cherchent de nouveaux moyens discret et
en même temps visible c'est toute la
difficulté merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous car à l'achat bourg merci pour
ce superbe reportage natalia morozova
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
bruno bruno daroux merci bruno merci à
vous tous deux heures suivis brut avec
nous et sur france 24